hello oh no way bro
I'm Francis Foster oh come on dog you
got to do better than that I agree with
you thank you sorry man yeah there was
just something there's something great
about having [ __ ] nothing you know
because nobody can take anything from
you I didn't want people to see my
background right and where I'm from yeah
and think ah that that's me the last
people that really anybody felt safe to
make fun of in like mainstream media
felt like
um poor white people you know yeah like
we did it all
like laughter will keep you warm you
know it's like so if you don't have
anything poor people sit around they're
more connected you know uh there's not
as much Sheltering from the world
there's not any like Hedges or any Gates
all your shit's hanging out the window
we don't do you guys have like uh
different pets and stuff dogs yeah yeah
what about also hamsters yes yes okay so
we're normal people over there yeah I
don't think anybody could realistically
look at me
and think that I've
never said the wrong thing
is what's the one thing
bad not bad
and I sat out there and watched smoke
the cigarette out there
right out there and that's the one thing
no one's talking about huh and that's
the one thing I was talking about there
was seven of these women in there
I can see why you brought it up
thank you
hey KKK we're advertising the ideal
product for you hmm will it be booked
that explains how anyone who disagrees
with powerful Russian men like me must
grovel at my feet three generations of
my family have been super ultra light
Fly Away skin and bone-only boxing
champion uh not really mate we're
advertising manual which is a men's
health company that specializes in hair
loss treatments I have plenty of her not
on your head good point you destroyed
you that it affects all kitchens I
started losing her at 12 which is very
late by Russian standards all you need
to do is fill out a free questionnaire
and Manuel will refer you to one of
their licensed clinicians and they will
then provide you with only clinically
proven medically backed hair loss
treatments based on your needs no longer
will you be doomed to looking like a
malnourished Russian gangster this is
incredible news the treatments are
effective in 9 out of 10 men join over a
hundred thousand men who use manual to
treat their hair loss they have an
180 day money back guarantee so it's
risk-free don't suffer in silence get it
sorted I will take manual and soon I
will have beautiful thick men like
Russian pop star Sergey saksamov
I can't believe you made up something
stop hand loss now Before It's Too Late
by using the code trigger
5010 or clicking the link in the
description for 50 of your first order
and 10 off your second that is trigger
five zero one zero for fifty percent of
first order and ten percent of second
order goodbye
hello oh no way bro
no [ __ ] way dog
that's not real
man what is look we do a formal intro
all right let's just get it over there
all right
that's how we normally start our
interviews let's get it over with right
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster oh come on dog you gotta
do better than that I agree with you
thank you sorry man I'm not trying to
tell you what to do you know what you're
doing but you gotta try harder bro
all right
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant guest today is
already taking the piss out of us it's
the amazing American comedian Theo Von
welcome to trigonometry you guys have we
call it autism
I don't know what you guys call it bro
but we got it over here everybody's got
it everybody's got it every celebrity
has it when they have a movie coming out
right they get it like the week before
bro they get autism and then the movie
comes out and then they fix it or
whatever you know but you guys
definitely bro what makes you think we
have launches oh I grew up around a ton
of autism we used to have a lot of
people a lot of adult like in middle age
kind of women with their shirts off
yelling stuff
um that's autism right there okay it's
good to know it's educational yelling at
Vehicles yeah let me explain something
for the viewers because they're not used
to seeing us like this yeah right all
right we just did The Joe Rogan show and
halfway through the thing he sparked up
a massive blunt yeah so we are a little
bit stoned yep and you've been taking
the piss out of out of us for the last
20 minutes yeah yeah um
and I think you're going to carry on
with that uh but listen uh you're very
famous here in the US fewer people know
about you in the UK uh and one of your
favorite routines that I love is you
talk about growing up uh it's a routine
about white privilege where you talk
about growing up the way that you did
yeah but what's your backstory man how
did what's your story my back story
pretty much you know I grew up in
Louisiana so Louisiana is a French
territory it was like a French territory
I think we bought it from France right I
don't know if they I don't know what
happened actually but
we lived there when I was young and it
was good man you know a lot of uh
you know it was just a lot of like
um a lot of like uh you have hitchhiking
and stuff in your country yeah yeah a
lot of people like that yeah you know
right yeah a lot of people that are
hitchhiking but they're not leaving yeah
they're just staying oh it's so it's a
place where people end up basically yeah
people end up people get dropped off
people hide a lot of pirates used to
come through there a long time ago in
the history yeah and um you didn't go up
to that period right no no oh yeah I'm
modern you know or semi-modern time
right right but yeah so I grew up there
man I had my dad was real old and my
mother was regular aged and we grew up
there and we had a nice time pretty much
not that great but uh the place was good
a lot of good uh recipes yep and
um what else I'm trying to think that
you guys would know about tell us the
stuff you think we don't know about just
tell us everything that I don't think
you know about yeah
well
do you guys have like um
like uh do
do people do you guys like go on
vacation
sure yeah and what do you call it
holiday yeah that's good
let me think about what else
um we don't do you guys have like uh
different pets and stuff yes yeah okay
dogs yeah yeah what about also hamsters
yes yes okay so we're normal people over
there yeah yeah we have the same [ __ ]
that you do okay all right we speak the
same language all right I mean it
doesn't sound the same when it comes out
of us but it's the same language I
promise you yeah yeah I'm trying to
think of what else I was trying to I was
gonna think about asking you guys man
um because I never knew that much about
Britain to be honest with you I like uh
oh what about the Welsh tell me about
that right the Welsh man well the Welsh
see Britain is is Tiny compared to
America obviously yeah but it's also got
you know different countries within the
union full countries within the union so
four states yeah you do but except they
speak different languages for
you oh really yeah see it Welsh have got
me like right so you've got them the
Irish the northern Irish yes Irish no no
but they like blowing [ __ ] up man yeah
man oh like Joe Joyce and them boys eh
yeah yeah exactly I don't know Joy Joyce
is but I'll go with it and so they've
got daily I don't know who Joe said that
it could be completely he's an online
yeah he fights online he fights Senior
Citizens online
they meet up in parking lots and stuff
and fight it's like senior citizens okay
so definitely not like that yeah okay no
no no there was a big conflict there and
they were using bombs to blow [ __ ] up oh
Christ that's why I'm saying to take it
easy because I don't want to get blown
up yeah exactly right so you've got and
then you've got fair enough that is more
than fair and then you've got the
Scottish yeah
they're [ __ ] hey but they're good yeah
yeah they're great so you've got on this
tiny Island Man and Northern Ireland
over there you've got all these
different cultures and different
languages and they all hate the English
oh really yeah man so that that's it
they don't like you guys right no one
likes I mean I'm originally from Russia
so it's even worse but yeah oh wow yeah
so you guys are fighting right now too
huh yeah and that's taking forever huh
yeah that's crazy yeah you think they
get it done quicker right that's crazy
man yeah well uh let me think about
whatever tell us about you your Story
come on man like what do you mean like
let me think about what I'm saying yeah
let me think um
my story is yeah I just
I just grew up
and you know I grew up just like in a
regular place just like a lot of people
like betting on like peop like dogs
would have babies and people would bet
on how much babies they were gonna have
and like um
people uh saw a guy die one time in a
fire people threw him in a fire
um well that sounds completely Lawless
just like sounds like Scotland a little
but like kind of like but in like you
know they have a lot of like good food
but incest right yeah see I'm not gonna
lie to you it does sound a little bit
like Scotland but right this I thought
the Scottish were wild that sounds
considerably more wild yeah yeah I've
heard I mean I yeah the Scottish I've
heard are pretty I heard it's pretty
unbelievable over there but um yeah so
that's I mean I guess what else was it
like well how did you get into stand up
um
I think my dad was just really old when
I was a kid and so I would make jokes
about everything you know right I would
try to change my reality that's
interesting what does that mean Theo
you'd like to change your reality well I
wanted a different reality you know I
didn't like the reality that I had and
so I wanted something different you know
and so I wanted to be different or feel
different or you know have different
chants than I thought felt like I had
probably in the world I felt like I
probably didn't have a strong chance
what was that Phil
what was what why why did you feel like
you didn't have a strong chance I think
just because of where I was from you
know just like poor white trash you know
like not we weren't trashy we were like
and we were just like poor you know just
like I don't know people just kind of
treat you different people in the
neighborhood don't have as much
opportunity you know a lot of not a lot
of people kind of get out of there and
do pretty well yeah so I think yeah I
think I was like I want to have a you
know I want to have a real chance you
know and so I started to find ways to
like adjust my reality mostly with
um you know using my imagination or
um you know I would like
do things like I don't know like bike to
school so I didn't have to ride the bus
from like with the poor kid just stuff
like that you know so yeah I don't know
is that what you're asking yeah yeah
that's great you know what's I find
really interesting about that is uh you
very few people who grow up from that
type of background field have that drive
do you know what I mean because most
people it doesn't matter where they're
born into they look around and they just
want to be the same as everyone else for
obvious reasons you think that's true I
think I believe that yeah yeah man oh
wow but you were you have were different
what was it about that who gave you that
or how did you get it or how did you get
it damn that's a good question man
I think um
I don't know I think I just didn't like
things so much that they didn't I didn't
have any other they had to be different
you know right I just
um I don't know it's a good question man
I never thought about it you know yeah I
just like
you know I would get involved in
different stuff that seemed like I'd
have new opportunities or find good
friends who I felt like you know weren't
going to be stuck in the same spaces I
don't know I think I just maybe
maneuvered well amongst it all yeah you
know kind of yeah but I miss it
sometimes I miss just some of the
Simplicity of it what do you mean by
that fail just people like you know just
my mates back then and stuff you know
just had a buddy like I used to work on
this farm for a while and I had a buddy
who would
he'd take his shirt off and go lay on
the concrete after it rained you know
just to stay you know because he liked
the feeling of the concrete on his skin
that's but that's really interesting
because people would look at you and go
oh this guy is you know he's a he's a
comedian he's successful he makes good
money he's he's got everything and yet
you look back at a time where you were
growing up poor yeah and you say that
you miss it
yeah there was just something there's
something great about having [ __ ]
nothing you know because nobody can take
anything from you right you know when
you got nothing you got literally have
nothing to [ __ ] lose other people say
to each other oh you got nothing to lose
that's the [ __ ] you know yeah but
when you have nothing dude it's just God
it's nice because you I mean you
absolutely you have nothing to lose man
and there's no
I feel like that's as free as you can
feel you know so you felt free but you
also felt a very strong drive to get
somewhere right yeah I think I just
didn't like I think there was enough
propulsion like you know my dad was so
old it was so embarrassing and and and
you know how old was it he was 70 when I
was born he was born in 1910. holy [ __ ]
he was a senior citizen right you have
that in your they call it senior citizen
what do you call it attention pensioners
yeah
that's crazy dude really yeah yeah all
these pensioners huh so you you your dad
was 70 when you were born he was older
mate
wow he was an older guy and
he was just you know he was getting you
know older and so he would you know
he would you know he was just kind of he
would let me drive as soon as I was tall
enough you know and just he was kind of
a bit lazy so he would just kind of let
me drive him around and stuff you know
when I was probably 11 and 12 you know
and um
what was it like he liked to eat peanuts
too and he would let me hold all the
shells all the time
what's it like being a kid when your dad
like when you said your dad was old I
expected like to be like oh he had me
when his 40s or early 50s yeah I'm not
70. what was I like being a kid walking
into school and you your dad looks like
your granddad yeah I think I would
pretend a lot that he was my granddad so
people didn't know and what was it like
man it was like
um
it was kind of sad I think because it
made me angry at time
you know it made me very
you know if I look at it part of it was
sad because I it made me angry at time
you know it made me feel like time
wasn't fair or it didn't do things
fairly right you know so it gave me like
it gave me a grudge against time right
maybe that sounds kind of crazy but
once you have a grudge against time
your whole perception gets altered
because now you can have
feelings towards
uh
things that people normally wouldn't
have feelings towards that make any
sense like what give us an example just
like you don't use it here maybe
somebody think I have a grudge against
time no it seems strange right right so
I think as a kid when I thought that
then it gave my
it gave my imagination like oh this is a
way you could think of this you know so
I think it kind of inspired my
imagination in a weird way to like um
want to be more creative you know yeah
so it was kind of a net I don't know if
that makes any sense no no it does make
it I can't explain it all because I
don't know that all I don't know you
know I don't know all the words a lot of
times you know a lot of times people you
know like Rogan's great at knowing what
he's thinking and saying it yeah you
know I'm not that great at that right
yeah you know but what's really
interesting is your background you said
you had a grudge against time does that
mean like you realized
life is finite there's an end to it so
you had to make the most of every of
every second because you saw that your
dad was older is that kind of what you
meant or is it I think it may I was just
pissed at every the way things shook out
you know I was pissed at the way that
time did things yeah yeah you know yeah
I was just like oh time why do you do it
like that you know
um and that made you want to sort of
look at the world differently okay yeah
I think it just gave my image I I don't
know I think you know having an old dad
Alters a lot of things because
um
like for one the way I communicate with
other men like I didn't my dad wasn't
around a lot and so I never really
learned how long to look at somebody in
the eyes when I talk to them you know
um so that was like tough for me to like
adjust to over time you know and it
might seem like a strange thing or
whatever no I know exactly what you mean
but you learn it from like you know
doing it with your dad or whatever so
you know I think just little things like
that you know
um but yeah I'm not trying to be
Melancholy or have anything no no no
this is really interesting and listen uh
how did you get from you so you have
this creative mind you're making jokes
with people when you're a kid you want
to create a different you're creating a
different reality in your mind I wanted
to seem different like I didn't want
people to see my background right and
where I'm from yeah and think uh that
that's me right I get it and it is me
like in some of my heart and some of my
spirit but it's not I didn't choose it
right of course I don't like to be a
part of things that I don't choose that
makes sense me neither so how do you go
from that to stand up
um we'll stand up
you just
you
you're fully responsible
you know they said it was the hardest
thing to do you know I got out to Los
Angeles and they're like this is the
hardest thing to do
and um
I had done a television show in America
reality show right when I was younger
okay
today's a different kind of day for Theo
like about the past month I've seen like
I'm in limbo kind of like I'm like I'm
between like lives kind of like part
Ghost part human my father died died a
couple years ago sorry to hear that and
then my mother actually lives down in
Tucson yeah I think at the age of 14 my
mother emancipated me like legally
emancipated me like signing the contract
and everything that just says that I'm
responsible for my own actions and
whatnot I mean I think I was kind of a
special kid growing up and I really like
I could use like a lot of effects and I
needed a lot of attention she couldn't
do it I mean it's gonna be hard on me in
the future I think because I don't
really know how to care about somebody
give us know what we're doing
clueless
I wonder what kind of people y'all think
would be here like well I knew they
would be between 18 and 24 and I knew it
was going to be three girls and three
guys yeah I got this dream that I got
here and everyone else was Japanese and
I didn't speak a word Japanese I have a
big I can't deal with Asian people that
much I don't think
he's 19. he's young
um he probably hasn't been around a lot
of people of color
what in the hell is the uh that's what I
think people think of me when they first
talk to me you get to know me they don't
really understand me because I mean a
lot of times I don't even understand
myself you know I'm surprised as other
people are at some of the things that
come into my head are some of the things
that I think about
they just don't know me yet they don't
need to jump on my case I mean I'm not
uh I'm not jumping on their case about
anything whenever people meet me for the
first time they laugh at me or something
like that I mean I just don't understand
it sometimes I've always felt that I was
different than other people in a way I
mean we're in a group right now but
right now I'm totally alone
it's cool life takes you different ways
and whips you around like leaves in the
wind it's cool how life can just set you
on a breeze and show you your country
and have the most fun you know that
you've maybe ever had and learned the
most about yourself that you've ever
learned hey hey you've seen your song
dude oh yeah it's about time right now
well lion gotta hurry to get all fixed
up I got an extra space and the cab of
my truck all I have to do is just like
strap on my seat belt keep it you know
kind of loose and just kind of enjoy the
ride that we're going on I'm just gonna
inhale everything and just like let it
just marinate in my lungs it's been nice
and it's gonna get even better I Can
Only Imagine
people you know always think it's
ridiculous as bollocks or whatever you
say bollocks right yeah we do it's
bollocks
so
the show you did yeah or it was it was a
good popular right very popular but it
was just
societal wise you know people just kind
of
pushed it off you know yeah even though
now some of those shows are very popular
and stuff yeah and so
people were and I kept hearing oh
stand-up comedy is the hardest thing to
do so I was like oh I'm gonna do that
then you know I want to do the hardest
thing that you have to do
so that nobody can say that I'm
that I couldn't do
that I'm so you couldn't associate me
with anything else I didn't want to be
because I'd been part of something that
people were like oh no we don't like
this right I wanted to say okay well
if you're not gonna like me you're then
you're gonna have to not like me yeah on
my own
on my own wow you know and so I felt
like stand-up was the only way to do
that because it's just
you know it's just you
and it's just
there's no cheating there's no nepotism
or whatever or nepotism
nepotism yeah yeah there's no need net
pots nepotism your dad can't help you
right yeah yeah you know in front of a
crowd yeah on a Saturday night your dad
can't [ __ ] help but he might be able
to help you get you in the door he can
help he can pack the audience a couple
times but as soon as it starts to show
up on his uh too much on his invoices
he's gonna stop doing it you know and so
that's what I liked there was no
I was in control over what you thought
of me
right and it was totally up to me and
that finally seemed fair to me right
because I think that life didn't
honestly seem that fair before that to
me
now
that's just how I thought and I don't
think that
you know I'm not trying to be a downer
no no I think it just kind of that's I
think that's honestly probably how I
thought yeah is that I want you to
if you're gonna say something about me
you're not going to be able to base it
on anything but myself you know right
yeah so that felt to me felt pretty good
stand up is very honest right when
you're on that stage you're either
making people laugh or you're not yeah
that's it and you're making people feel
you're making them do something but
you're doing it you know and they're
doing it too
you know it's funny sometimes I would
rather be the person in the audience you
know really I'm not good at it you
really like I'm not how do you mean
you'd rather be the person in the
audience because they're having a blast
man you know I'm having fun too but I'm
having to work and like do the stuff but
they just are having fun you know I
think sometimes I almost admired seeing
that so much that if I wasn't able to
easily be that person then at least I
could be a part of like creating that
you know yeah
um so yeah anyway sorry it's a bit
long-winded no no tell me something
about you guys
genuinely fear what you're saying is
really interesting and and it's not
long-winded you're going you're talking
about yourself and also you're talking a
little less than most of our guests too
yeah less than less than I told you we
we normally do quite serious
conversations which is why we're asking
you because what we're interested in is
you clearly have a brilliant mind for
comedy yeah right you do otherwise you
wouldn't be where you are you wouldn't
have had the success so what we're
interested in is like how do you think
how did you get there how do you look at
life so this is all perfect okay yeah
because I didn't know exactly so I
didn't want to be doing something that
was wrong no no no you're doing nothing
that's wrong okay cool man yeah yeah
yeah so uh yeah I guess that's how I
think a lot about it you know I think
um
yeah I think that's an answer of that
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
the sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape uh not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
we reference it at the start of the
interview one of my our favorite
routines of yours is the white privilege
routine it's brilliant it's brilliant
but I think the reason it hits
it's because you're telling the truth
yeah so I had to step as guide us
through how did you how did you make
that happen how did you well they didn't
like you know sometimes like poor poor
white people get left out of like the
the poverty conversation I feel like
sometimes Maybe
it's hard to like
it's kind of [ __ ] sometimes you're like
if you're white right and I'm polish a
Nicaraguan right and but if you are
white or looked at as a white you know
Whitey honky wiggers whatever they call
them you know
um
I don't know what they call them in
what do you guys calling them
yeah a couple [ __ ] you know little
chabs right at AR
um if you are chavs or just regular
white people poor white people then yeah
I felt like a lot of times
um when people think of like poor they
think of just uh ethnicities first a lot
of times you know and so and you always
feel bad anyway because white people
you're just supposed to have money right
so automatically out of the gate you're
like how the [ __ ] do we not have
a little bit more money than this right
right if you've had a couple generations
and you've shown up in the you know in
the correct uniform yeah how would you
not have a bit more of a you know
Treasure Chest you know but but you know
that's what you get born into and so
that's that and uh and yeah it kind of
feels like you don't really get a voice
sometimes you know
um and then
yeah so I think that was part of my
thing it was like
I'm I ride the same bus as the poor
black kids the poor we only had black
and white in our town
but like you know when people think of
um
when people think of yeah helping like
sometimes they they would miss us you
know it would feel like sometimes and
now also
maybe that's just a feeling and maybe
that's not even the reality but it was
my perception sometimes you know I
wasn't angry at black people for it I
just was like well this is my truth you
know right and sometimes it feels like
uh
they don't know where to put that truth
in like a mainstream
space right it doesn't fit that
if you're not if you're poor and white
and not a racist person or you know
somebody who's mating with their
you know siblings or whatever then
you um
they don't it's almost like yeah work
yeah like you don't exist but you do and
there's a lot of you you know and and
that's really interesting because you
know whenever like you see people in the
UK like comedians do like what they
would call a racist voice they would use
your accent yeah yeah you know what I
mean like and immediately you're just
stigmatizing a whole load of people
the vast majority of whom are nice and
decent and whatever else yeah
yeah that was always crazy yeah I mean
that was really rough during like a lot
of um when the Trump and Hillary I think
it was I thought that was the campaign
but one of the campaigns it was like
everybody just started really the last
people that Hollywood was a or like I
don't know if it's just Hollywood the
last people that really anybody felt
safe to make fun of in like mainstream
media felt like
um poor white people
you know yeah like we did it all right
if we did it all we'd have [ __ ] done
it differently yeah I mean we'd have
something to show for it you know so I
think that yeah that [ __ ] yeah but that
was the only one you could pick on so I
think it's Brave if somebody tries to
pick on somebody else you know I think
it's a little bit braver and I like that
that's one of the things that's always
kind of kept me
wanting to stay in the game is like how
how close to the middle of that tight
rope can I get you know right
um so you like getting close to the line
and feeling a bit of that heat there
yeah dude
yeah I mean I'm you know I don't like to
pretend that I'm like a fancy person or
that I've never done things wrong or
anything like that I've you know I'm not
I'm far from anything I'm just a regular
person you know just trying their best
or whatever I don't know but like I
never
you know I never
what was the question again
I was talking about getting close to the
line
yeah I wish that they would [ __ ] you
know I wish that if everybody was more
cool than I think the line would be it
would be a lot more fun you know so you
feel restricted
let me think
do you feel like there's jokes that you
want to do that you're worried about
doing is that what you mean yeah man
yeah I do but also I think you gotta be
also like crafty yeah you know like if I
hear something that's just like racist
or just [ __ ] like that [ __ ] makes me
mad but if you have something that is
creative
then that always should be able to at
least be
admired in some way you know yeah but
now yeah it's a little bit more cagey
what's it like in your country a lot
less really yeah yeah yeah so comedians
have been arrested for jokes we've had
investigations by the police into into
comedians telling jokes someone told the
joke and the police turn up and go
explain that joke to us what if you
tickle someone
that's harassment yeah that's sexual
assault oh yeah but yeah but that's
where we are in in the UK man damn bro
y'all gotta get out dude get another
vote we'll send the boat back over tell
me about it but there's nowhere there's
nowhere new place to go now you know
yeah because I thought a lot of people
were going to come back to you guys in a
boat yeah I thought we're gonna yeah how
come just because it like you know I
thought people would be like all right
we're out you know we're gonna we're
gonna scoot on out yeah but it's
interesting isn't it because America is
sort of the land of the free right
you're supposed to be able to say
whatever the hell you want make the
jokes Etc but you don't feel that that's
the situation now well I think it used
to be but now like the moderate uh
I like that
that's a still I don't really I don't
get too scared
if you have a crowd you can go to the
audience yeah you can do what you want
yes you know yes so they are more
you know that's a little more normal I
think if you're just trying to like
come up and learn in the clubs I bet
it's it could feel more restricted right
that's what I always say as well like
the theobons and the bill Burrs and the
Joe Rogan's there's no problem with for
them but as you if you're coming up to
the clubs it's really really a lot
tighter you know I think probably for
yeah I mean it's just it's definitely
been like uh you know it's been a very
I don't know if it's been like a pro
black time in Hollywood kind of you know
and in comedy and stuff like that
um it's Pro diversity right yeah
pro-diversity probably so that's
probably a better way to say it you know
I think I also think a lot of times with
diversity of black and white just
because that's all I grew up with yeah
that's all we had growing up yeah but um
and so maybe I didn't ever know maybe
there were a lot more white people in
comedy I don't remember I never super
remembered it that way but maybe it was
you know I mean my favorite Comics were
like Richard Pryor and Chris Rock are
probably my favorites
um this guy [ __ ] i-man War
um so I don't know if maybe there were
maybe there was like a racial ceiling
I'm sure there used to be because there
used to be a one on everything right
yeah women the same right yeah so I
think you want to have some different
you know I think
you there's also the thought of like
well
this
ethnicity this skin color has had its
time now it's time for others yeah skin
colors so and some of that you almost
have to think well [ __ ] maybe that's
how time played it out you know it's
like
I don't you know I don't know what
time's big plan is at the end so it's
hard to really get a full breadth of it
you know by just attaching myself to the
moment that I'm in even though it may
feel uncomfortable at times you know and
I may get pissed like oh [ __ ] you know
but um
but me personally you know I feel like
I'm just you know I'm doing okay and um
you know I'm doing my you know I feel
like I'm trying to connect where I can
with people and uh I don't know I don't
know what else to say right now see ya
do you ever feel right
do you ever worried are you ever worried
that someone will look over one of your
old bits and go whoa
that's a bit naughty
and then try and start something or
cancel you do you know what I mean do
you ever worry about that yeah I do
sometimes I think everybody listens to
their old stuff though and is kind of
unimpressed by it in some ways because
you're evolving yeah unimpressed is
different though brother because if if
you are unimpressed if I'm unimpressed
with something you've done I'm not going
to come after you and try and ruin your
career right but for some people if
that's what I think he's getting at
which is like are you worried that
people you know you said the wrong thing
which wasn't even the wrong thing back
then and now it is and people are going
to come after you or is that not a
concern for you I don't I don't think
it's not a concern but I think I don't
think anybody could realistically look
at me
and think that I've
never said the wrong thing
you know what I'm saying like I know
what you say to be honest with you
you know right I was right yeah I mean I
was raised in the breadth of the wrong
thing you know so I've heard all of its
songs yeah right
um but do you think that makes you a
better comic feel like in the UK we've
got this generation of very like Rich
Posh middle class you know uh went to
Oxford and Cambridge you know they're
very smart comedians do you sometimes
think that the way you grew up the fact
you come from such a poor background so
that just makes you funnier that
adversity that stuff you came through
um
yeah I think it get well yeah you gotta
have more the worst [ __ ] is
the thing you know when
the word if you don't have any and this
wasn't us but this is just like a
hypothetical thing if you don't have any
like
like laughter will keep you warm you
know it's like so if you don't have
anything poor people sit around they're
more connected you know uh there's not
as much Sheltering from the world
there's not any like Hedges or any Gates
all your shit's hanging out the window
it's like so you're more like
um
these things just are a lot more real
right it's hard to hide being poor is
pretty hard to hide you know and so uh
yeah and poor people are outdoors more
they just hang out outside more and So
you you're talking with people and
laughing people are going to want to
laugh so you start laughing more
um so that's I think a lot of that just
makes sense like we hung outside a lot
you know maybe just as kids but also
parents were out there smoking and they
had some people were
um
what do you call it pedophiles and they
had
um you know people that have pedophiles
out there trying to [ __ ] hang out
with you and [ __ ] and so like
everybody's Milling around and it's just
like it's a good
soup to [ __ ] you know make dumplings
out of you know so it's a good soup to
make humor out of you know really yeah
because when you've got everything right
there all the ingredients it's just it's
a great time to pull jokes you know
so I missed that's some of the stuff
that I miss is just the reality was
right there all the time you know yeah
and it's fun that was funny yeah uh it
was fun yeah and does does the life of
stand-up does that make you happy you
enjoy it
well it's interesting because he gets
pretty Lonesome as it you get more
successful in some ways yeah yeah yeah
it does it gets pretty Lonesome I think
in some ways
um but give us an example well like you
go to the audience now if you have a
bigger audience right you go there to a
theater and you go out and they come in
from this way and you come in from the
back and you kind of meet along this
line at the stage and there's not really
any co-mingling and then you both go
your separate ways you know whereas I
think with the clubs it used to feel a
little bit more like involved and you
and your buddies were always there
together but once you kind of go out
touring and you know kind of make your
way and find your success in it which is
awesome you uh you kind of have to be
it's not lonely but you a lot of that is
time you know with just you so I think
you have to learn to bring like your
mates along and your teammates or
whatever and um whatever out you know if
you bring animal or whatever if you
bring it you know snacks or animals or
whatever some people bring along same
thing yeah yeah okay yeah I guess
I guess man but that's interesting
yeah it's it's been interesting man yes
I don't know what we're supposed to be
talking about exactly there's nothing
that was supposed to happen we're just
having a conversation yeah yeah is this
but you guys are like detectives huh
yeah do we feel right to take this a
little bit a little bit is this
uncomfortable for you no I don't think
so I don't know
so but I don't feel like it is that much
maybe some moments okay yeah so that
but what we're trying to get to the
heart I I guess and we're trying to
understand Theo it's just like what
makes you tick what makes you tick the
way you work yeah and what like I guess
yeah I mean you guys are kind of like
um
it's like uh unfairness Hunters Maybe
does it feel like that is that what you
think yeah yeah how so like unfairness
Hunters like you hunt down things that
seem unfair
you know what that's a good description
yeah is it yeah is it fair enough I
think that's a fair description yeah
yeah I like that I like things to try
and be fair you know yeah and it's hard
to equivocate that or figure that out
you know right it's hard to figure it
out so I think you have to have people
that are hot on the case you know that's
a good description that's a really
really good description man yeah uh yeah
and we're not trying to start any [ __ ]
I'm just we're just curious about how
people see the world and from our
perspective we you know we we both come
from backgrounds where we feel fairness
is important people not being mistreated
is important you know people not being
picked on on the because of the way they
grew up or what their skin color is or
whatever yeah you know either way black
or white doesn't really matter right
um yeah it was yeah I mean like there's
never like the
when it came to like black white stuff
it always felt like it was the white
person's fault even if right you felt
like you know because the in our town
black people were having a tougher time
overall yeah you know and so
um you know a lot of times I felt like
they got the benefit of it out from
people maybe from authorities and stuff
they didn't I don't know what you know
that's like I just have only been just
me
um that's interesting that you say that
because like in the UK like we talk a
lot about like white privilege and look
if you've if you've come for money and
you're white you're definitely
privileged but there's loads of places
in the UK which is just like the places
that you grew up in like where these
people legitimately have nothing they've
got nothing you know and every day for
them is a struggle and then for people
to come along and go you're privileged
to me
you know right well yeah it's crazy
you're like oh well if I am at least
give me some of it yeah you know yeah
it's crazy man I think but also it's
like a lot of the people that say that
they they've never they're not from
those places no they've never been there
they don't know what it's like you know
a lot of people like in like
in Los Angeles you know a lot in some of
the community they
they didn't know what's even none of
them could even relate to anything I was
talking about because they just didn't
know it you know they were all like it
was mostly people from uh New York or LA
or Boston you know and it was more like
uh
just from a different kind of class of
society sometimes not always but maybe
that's going to start changing too I
think if there's less uh
uh if a lot like that overtly woke
programming kind of goes numb eventually
that will have to evolve because I don't
think that the entertainment industry
really has any
couth I don't know if that's the word or
not what does that mean I don't know
what it means I don't know what it means
you mean like clout do you mean like the
entertainment industry is dying fear no
I think but they don't have any real
like
moral compass I don't think yeah or
maybe that's not it that's [ __ ] crazy
no no no just talk about that small
that's interesting but they oh no no
this is what it is they just follow
where the money goes yeah yeah that's it
okay so I think it's work we go this way
tomorrow it's not work we go that way
right and sometimes the rest of us I
feel like get played I don't know if we
get played
it's almost like we're all just chasing
this tale and I don't know how it got
started but it's like
because no they're just doing it or
whoever they are this hypothetical day
right are just doing it just to get uh
you know
they just want us to
like they're just they're just doing it
to
create a trend or to make money or to do
whatever
our reaction to it also becomes its own
business in a way it's all bizarre I'm
not smart enough to know no but that's
just that is a very smart point that
you've just made yeah and I don't think
it is I do yeah you know well I don't
even know what the point is to be real
honest with you yeah no but that was a
good that was a great point you know the
fact that that is its own industry and
then the reaction to the thing is its
own industry as well and you know and
that creates jobs and money so that
everybody is in their interest to keep
this [ __ ] going right in a weird way
yeah yeah it's what it all is and then
in the end it's entertainment
so it's like what can we really even say
but that we were entertained you know
yeah I mean it's painful Sometimes some
of the entertainment can you know it can
be painful or it can hurt your feelings
but
um
but yeah I don't know you know
I don't know also what it feels like to
be a different ethnicity in America I
don't know what a lot of that feels like
so it's really tough to say
things
uh but I shouldn't feel ashamed to be
able to also say what my own experience
was like right no not at all I agree
with that yeah so
it's interesting it's been an
interesting line to walk it was it was
definitely tough though when people were
making fun of just
like we were the I was like my place
where I was from was like the last
scapegoat you know yeah and then they
ran out or or they'll just keep using
that one you know yeah but
hey Francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium-like TV
then simply sit back and watch all your
hard-earned money disappeared down the
toilet what about advertising was
trigonometry why would I do that when I
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets two million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your advert will be written by
two professional comedians yeah that's
right we're hiring two professional
comedians
when we make our ads funny and engaging
to the point where some people say the
ads are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing at
triggerpod.co.uk that's marketing at
triggerpod dot Co dot UK advertise with
us and we'll get your business canceled
and what is that like when you just see
people all the time like go towards like
the butt of the joke the butt of the
joke you're the butt the joke do you
know what I mean yeah I think I didn't
take it personally but I took it
personally for the people from where I'm
from yeah you know and I guess maybe I
did take it personally some like uh
yeah I would see I would see Comics say
like all these white [ __ ] and
just things that was just like if I ever
said that about somebody else it would
be right yeah you know that's that's
that's why I you know I I some people
think I'm white some people think I'm
not white and that was one of the
reasons we started the show because I
saw this happening like people were just
using it as like uh
uh I think that you can just use like
that you know yeah and it's crazy
because if something happens to another
you know it's never a racial thing when
it happens to a white person but it
happens to a black person it feels more
racial more often yeah but then that's
also I can't tell if that's real
sometimes or if that's just my right and
there's a terrible history there right
as well yeah total responding to yeah so
it's like
yeah and that's where I think yeah those
people a lot of those people probably
mad at time just like I was you know
probably had a grudge against it in some
ways well so uh we're done
you'll have people done oh I don't even
know if we are no no no I was just gonna
say uh we uh we asked a couple of
questions from our supporters uh once
the interview is over but okay thank you
for your time I hope it wasn't too
uncomfortable for you man it's just uh
we like to find out what what makes
people take what they think and you've
you probably don't think this but you've
got a very interesting perspective on
life that most people don't not only
have but they never get to hear on on
the on the screen
you see what I'm saying yeah I guess I
do man I don't know man I mean
I don't know I I I try sometimes I wish
I serviced my own
uh opinions better
would you ever feel that way how'd you
mean you mean like you you communicate
to them about it or yeah or just I yeah
I still just wish that I could service
them better even within entertainment
you know or within like my stand-up and
stuff it does feel I guess a little
sometimes restrictive you know
um
you know or It's just tough to navigate
yeah yeah but
but then in my life man nothing's ever
really been [ __ ] easy you know and I
probably wouldn't like it if it was
honestly
how come I don't know
I just don't
think I would take to it really if
something were real easy really yeah you
like the hot stuff you seek it out I
don't know if I like it but I just think
that it but I think that becomes like a
ray it becomes what it feels
it becomes common enough for you
I don't know if you trust it more I
don't know but they say not you know I
don't know what I'm talking about
but no I hate what you're saying so the
last question we ask and this is going
to sound funny given what you've just
said is what's the one thing when when
bad not bad
it's been a long day dude you asked him
the question yeah okay so Theo the last
question we always ask is what's the
thing
[Music]
is this mere this is a good mirror yeah
it is a good mirror did this chain be
out the whole time oh no it's good
all right what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
um
I think they
oh dude I remember one time I saw these
massive Birds right they call them in
your yeah it's beautiful strong
uh
I swear bro I went to this I went to
this place called Newcastle have you
heard of this yes yeah Newcastle and
this taxi drops me off and there was
these it was like a part like a
I'm supposed to look like a bachelorette
party or something and and this foyer of
like a big there was a big room like a
big window and they were in there naked
you know what do you call it
tits yes yes tits
and they were beating each other with
pillows in there bro and I sat out there
and watched smoked a cigarette out there
right out there and that's the one thing
no one's talking about huh that's the
one thing I was talking about there was
seven of these women in there
I can see why you brought it up
it was serious man oh
sounds fantastic well
it was serious bro see I can't even do
it justice because you can't even
believe that it could happen could you
how who would get seven women naked and
have them pillow fight in front of a big
huge pitcher window someone's thought
they wanted to be seen for you I don't
know man that's [ __ ] that's beautiful
bro
it's good [ __ ] man all right so where
you guys headed next man uh we're going
to see the comedy show that you're part
of oh [ __ ] man I forgot
oh man uh listen thanks for coming on
Theo where can people find you online
where do they follow you just find me
online man
um are you on tour nope not right now
I'll probably get back over there to the
UK at some point though yeah I want to
come to the Welsh I want to come to
Scotland again I want to come to
um Ireland Stonehenge do people play
Stonehenge yes yeah hell yeah not played
Stones Ubuntu style you've played what
do you mean plates I want to play it do
people ever play it do a show there
Stonehenge yeah no
I want to [ __ ] play it for you you
see that's what made you that attitude
that that's it I've never met anyone no
one's ever played Stonehenge no man it's
so historical monuments yeah you can't
what are you talking about man you see
this is a day above she got some
mentality that makes you feel one yeah
that's the difference between an
American and a Brit a Brit will look at
that and go that's that's an ancient
Monument an American will be like yeah I
could feel this
yeah man that'd be wild dude yeah I
gotta get over there man and see what's
going on more and get a little bit more
Intel on you guys man but I'm uh yeah
I'm all right let us know when you're
over we'll look after you yeah man we'll
take you out all right Theo a couple of
quick questions from my locals and we'll
let you go all right
we didn't even have any British kids we
had some guy with like not like a lisp
or something but something had happened
to it he'd gotten hit in the jaw real
good and he said people thought he was
British all the time well because he
added a speech impediment yeah this is
gonna make a great behind the scenes bit
they called him a queer all the time and
they said he was British and stuff but
he just had a speech impediment here
[Music]
thank you